who would you say  is the it guy now rob  well for sure it's i know who it is and  it's it's it's somebody who's had it it  went away and now he's back at it again  and it's harry styles i feel like harry  is the it guy he's a little older i  obviously was the biebs justin bieber  for for a long time but my sons who are  much more plugged in would probably tell  me that there's somebody even younger  and more on the forefront but but from  where i sit it feels a lot like it's  it's hairy now harry styles and you also  have that similar like boyish that yummy  that like pretty as well as sexy and  handsome you know how like it's sexy or  cute or funny and sexy like there's like  that four quadrants and you're two of  each like you guys are everything  when you see harry styles  having lived the life you did are you  like have the most fun with this it  makes me wish i had been a rock star